hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück auf
meinem kanal keine ahnung wie ihr hier
in verliert habe die selbst bereits im
titel eingeblendet wir schauen uns heute
einige min son die meine community also
ihr die lupe mit meinem gesicht gemacht
habt wenn man gerade seine schulsachen
ausgepackt hat und der lehrer dann sagt
dass ihr den raum wechseln müsste war
nicht so lustig kennt
jeder diese situation werde jetzt noch
zwei bis drei stunden lernen 2 - 3
gleich - 1 also ich wünsche einer stunde
fertig eine gute sache wie man das ganze
ein gehen kann wenn man nachts aus dem
fenster guckt dann sieht man dass es
dunkel ist
wow
nachts ist es auch kalt
draußen
wenn ich einen gemeinen brief
verschicken ist der postbote dann ein
brief
ehrlich gesagt
a
meine mutter mir nach zehn stunden sagt
dass es essen gibt das ist
real talk das was ich am meisten
vermisse ich wohl mittlerweile seit vier
jahren glaube ich schon alleine und das
ist ein zu beginn gar nicht aufgefallen
weil man halt dachte okay dann bestelle
ich mir jetzt halt was oder kochen wir
selbst war es aber mittlerweile immer
wenn ich zu hause bin meiner familie und
mama ruft essen du denkst einfach nur so
geil einfach nur nach oben gehen rein
schaufel und wieder weg und nichts
abspülen die stars sind schon so die
perks of having parents jeder hat
eltern aber das sind die vorteile davon
wenn man noch zu hause lebt hat gestern
mein heft wieder bekommen war echt
heftig
durch den bund
meine freunde und ich sind sehr
verschieden ich existiere sie nicht
allein sind die seite lukas kleiner
popel heißt also humor ist echt einfach
nicht vorhanden falls ihr euch übrigens
fragt die bilder hat jude rausgesucht
und mir hier in schnittprogramm gezogen
und deswegen reagiere ich da jetzt
gerade drauf also ich habe die noch
nicht vorher gesehen und noch eben ganz
kurz wenn euch das hier gefällt also
dass sich so alle 12 wochen mal auf
irgendwelche luca - reagiere da last auf
jeden fall meinen daumen hoch bei diesem
video hier das schaffen den 40.000 eine
große zahl aber wenn ihr da wirklich
bock drauf habt jetzt 1000 likes folgt
man auf instagram ich als laser luca
verlinkte mich da gern wenn ihr solche
ja unlustigen luca - macht und dann
kommt ihr vielleicht die nächste folge
dieser moment wenn du süß in der schule
mit hass und jeder etwas haben will
[ __ ] geht weg lars halt wirklich so also
ich weiß nicht wie es bei euch ist aber
meine mama hat mir früher nie etwas
süßes mitgegeben
okay manchmal wenn du das siehst ich hab
dich lieb und so aber ich habe halt
meistens immer nur so langweiliges
körnerbrot bekommen fand ich habe mir
sogar die letzten drei vier jahre in der
schule immer mein brot selber geschmiert
ich hatte schon scheiße aber wirklich
wenn man dann mal irgendwann was süßes
mit hatte alle kammern oder wenn man
kaugummis mit hatte oder so was was
passiert wenn luca in ein geschäft geht
der lauf
bei dir geht er der rechtsstreit melder
an
warum legen hühner eigentlich eierwerfen
können sie sie ja schlecht oder
warum liga überhaupt nicht lustig rede
ist ich halte das plakat luca -4 war
schon immer gut
schieferbein zwar immer also bei
irgendwelchen präsentation es gab auch
immer diese typische situation vom
lehrerzimmer du glaubst ich rede so
bescheuert wenn du dich schon mehrmals
wiederholt hast und ich versuch's
zusammenzureißen damit du der person
keine klatsche
ok auf der die flasche
hinten eindrücken naja beim laufen tut
es ein bisschen weh aber wenn ich vor zu
richtig super league kommt man auf so
war das auch immer so reisen wie
wirklich meine gesichtsausdrücke perfekt
zu der aussage passen aber gut ok
nächstes mitspieler haben mit der
familie ich bin ich leider nicht
er ist schuldig weil sarah ist
tatsächlich irgendwie immer blau wenn du
dich kurz weg dreht sondern die ganze
tafel voll geschrieben
da denkt sich hat ein wirklich fanpages
irgendwie auf instagram luca guckt um in
dieser szene in seinem video daraus
könnte ich nie machen mega mega geil
also wirklich von allen sachen die ihr
für mich macht auf instagram sei es
jetzt irgendwie zahnarzt zeichnungen ezb
nicht wirklich - aller geilsten es muss
nicht immer ein krasses fan art sein
sondern muss die einen zum lachen
bringen das ist das erste mal dass ist
das kann für mich den kompletten tag
verschönern ich habe mir neulich ein
dach gekauft ging aufs haus
da wie
gar nichts zu sagen notiz an mich selbst
wenn mein mathelehrer fragt was man
kürzen könnte ist ihr gehalt die falsche
antwort
wenn das
wenn du mit jemandem der schule bringt
alltag der krieg direkt eine backpfeife
wer ist der größte schummler im
dschungel mowgli
lustig kommt ein cowboy zum friseur geht
er wieder raus pony weg
das sind halt wirklich diese diese jobs
die wir uns schon im irakkrieg 1834
erzählt haben diese unnötigen mein gott
der sonne
kaka aber auch
ja wenn jemand gefühlte zehn jahre
schreibt und am ende nur ein ok kommt
was los mit dir
das war in dem es war auf der rückfahrt
und frankfurter flughafen 6 uhr morgens
und wir hatten den acht stunden flug aus
new york was los wird dir als gott mich
schuf dachte er keine ahnung was es wird
aber wird bestimmt lustig man ach so ich
habe übrigens meinen einem gymnastikball
ja ich bin komisch wenn man eine
haselnuss abrutschen unter das
kopfkissen league kommt nachts die
toffees
meistens ist wirklich so
angucke und schon bevor ich
es ist zu ende gelesen habe würde ich
mich töten ich habe den busfahrer
verarscht ich habe bezahlt und bin nicht
eigentlich wann er wo nehmt ihr diese
dummheit der rassist das weiße in vogel
kacke auch fokus dürfte über sonne
schwachsinn so lachen kann was ist der
unterschied zwischen schule und lidl
lidl lohnt sich
ja warum summen bienen
täglich kämen irgendwie liebig dieses
format hier schon aber irgendwie hat es
auch es gibt drei personen von denen man
kein outfit hören möchte piloten
zahnärzte und friseure
ja also
wo war das jetzt
dieser moment
der roller fahren willst aber der roller
gegen deinen knöchel knallt
habt ihr es nur roller genannt bei uns
dies immer cityroller wenn du city
fahren willst
ja ok rolle hat sich bessern und dann
auch wieder so die sprüche die da an
meinem kopf sind erste roller fahren und
dann du mist geburt ihr seid echt
absolute wahnsinn
es schaut gerade niemand lass mal
überkochen nudelwasser
ist halt wirklich die wahrheit der topf
steht da komplett friedlich
man guckt kurz weg guckt wieder hin beim
vulkanausbruch mit wasser an der stelle
des heutigen videos allerdings am band
meine damen und herren ihr habt einfach
auf instagram so krass viele - gemacht
in den letzten monaten jahren also
wirklich heiß der laser luca auf
instagram und wenn man da meine
markierten bilder durch geht jedes
zweite oder dritte ist mir mit meiner
hässlichen fresse braucht habe ein jude
gefragt ob sie nicht einfach mal ein
paar aussuchen kann sie hat jetzt 30
stücke ausgesucht und es ist unfassbar
schnell also sie ist die ganzen sachen
durchgegangen und hatte nach zehn
minuten 30 von eur - mit meiner fresse
also wenn ihr wollt dass ich das ganze
hier eventuell nochmal hochladen in
einer woche oder in zwei wochen keine
ahnung was schreibst du gerne und den
kommentare wie bereits gesagt jetzt ist
hause nike wenn ich da bock drauf habt
folgt auf instagram laser luca heiße ich
da damit ihr mich verlinken könnt und
dort niemals machen könnte
[Musik]